OK.
We have been saying that we're going to try
to at least keep the voicemail segment light
because of all of the horrible news that is
coming out.
So here's a call I got at our voice mail line
2 1 9 to David P. about whether I'm still
eating Sangh sandwiches in a particular way.
Take a list.
Halling, too.
Sorry.
Hi, David.
My name is Colt in the home.
I was just calling to just inquire if you've
changed your stance on your sandwich, your
style, flipping it upside down.
Just thinking about it.
It's a pretty regressive, disgusting way of
eating a sandwich.
And I was wondering if you have any thoughts
on her?
No.
Yesalis and I am still eating sandwiches in
the same way.
And one of the things I'm known for and I'm
trying to see if I can.
Let's see if I can do a little demo here for
you very quickly, as people may know.
Imagine that the writing on this piece of
paper on top of the piece of paper is ah,
the sesame seeds on top of a sesame seed bun.
So if you have the sandwich sort of bun up
on in front of you, the way I have always
eaten sandwiches is I take it and I flip it
as I bring it to my mouth.
I flip it.
So the sesame seed bun ends up pointing down.
If that makes sense, a lot of people have
been horrified that this is how I eat sandwiches.
But it has not changed.
I continue to eat sandwiches in that way.
I've been making great sandwiches during my
self-quarantine and I'm still flipping the
sandwich every way.
If that I know some people will probably cancel
memberships over that, but that is what I'm
doing.
Quick reminder.
Wednesday evening, March 25, 8:00 p.m. Eastern.
David Pakman Show Chess Tournament.
I will stream the tournament live on all four
of our video platforms.
Anybody can play.
Join me 8:00 p.m. and make an account on LEAP
Scoreboard to be ready.
Great bonus show for you today.
Thanks for watching.
We're here all week.